[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui jean
françois colossimo qui publie le sabre
et le turban un livre sur la turquie un
état qui aussi depuis toujours d'après
vous entre le sabre et le turban c'est à
dire entre la caserne et la mosquée mais
avec toujours le même but
vous nous direz lequel est elle un
baraton le jardinier en chef du château
de versailles est du domaine de barly
l'auteur du dictionnaire amoureux des
jardins qui ressort aujourd'hui en
version illustrée et l'on commence tout
de suite par ce qui caractérise notre
époque voici vos réponses en images
celle d'alain baraton d'abord de quoi
s'agit-il c'est une peinture juste une
photo et un marathon c'est une photo une
photo qui parle d'elle même je crois
on y voit donald trump vu de dos cette
photo explique tout d'un côté la
grandeur américaine s'est ainsi pas les
bras ballants la défaite c'est ce que
j'aime dans cette photo c'est qu'elle
n'a même pas besoin d'être légende et on
se doute de ce qui arrive à l'homme
qu'il ya des photographies on dirait
presque une illustration de norman
rockwell way et j'ai choisi également
cette photo depuis le départ donc
définitif et récent de valéry giscard
d'estaing
le débat qui avait été marqué par ses
propos à la télévision
on est un petit peu dans la même
situation les bras le long du corps on
voit toute la détresse tout là toute la
misère qui tombe sur un seul homme et
qu'il s'en va comme ça presque de
manière blood jeunes beaucoup cette
photo et votre image avoue jean françois
colossimo ben c'était ya pas très
longtemps à 7 à istanbul
doit on est près de l'ancienne
université d'istanbul du du grand bazar
et je dirais que c'est pas nos marques
au fond la question qu'on peut adresser
à l'état turc avant même que d'agresser
aux turcs eux mêmes bon nous sommes du
côté l'azerbaïdjan dit l'une
pourquoi pas mais l'autre dit stop à
l'agression arménienne et avec une
demande de justice
or je veux dire c'est assez simple ce
sont les arméniens du haut karabagh qui
ont été agressée certe l'affairé
complexe le ton pauvre draps mais ce
sont eux qui en fait sont dans la
position inverse à celle que décrit
cette pancarte est en fait un but là sur
une certaine réécriture de l'histoire
qui est tout à fait de mise en turquie
et qui voient là le turc comme une
victime comme quelqu'un d'encercler
comme quelqu'un d'agressé de l'extérieur
de l'intérieur et se turent que je
dirais encerclé en fait il se montra
nous un peu comme pour le coup enfermé
dans une sorte de contre histoire qui
explique cette mobilisation nationaliste
constante d'atatürk
erdogan est bien commençons avec votre
livre jean-françois comme si moh
[Musique]
jean-françois que le si mauvaise
historiens vous êtes éditeur vous publié
aujourd'hui le sabre et le turban aux
éditions du cerf édition que vous
dirigez c'est un livre sur l'été sur qui
on l'a dit api qui que nous n'aurions
jamais compris d'après vous un pays qui
aussi je vais dit entre deux pôles le
sabre et le turban la caserne et la
mosquée mais toujours dans la même
direction alors laquelle qu'elle est
laide direction la turquie moderne née
de l'effondrement de l'empiré ottoman et
elle surgit aussi après une forme de
trou noir dont elle n'est pas
responsable ce sont les jeunes turgeon
dire ottoman qui ont commis le génocide
des arméniens
mais ce pays qui sort des décomptes en
quelque sorte qui sort de l' angoisse de
l'idée très angoissé qui n'auraient pu
ne pas exister puisque le traité de
sèvres en 1920 définit une petite
turquie qui réduite au plateau
d'anatolie n'est ce pas ce pays que
mustafa kemal a en quelque sorte
reconquis par les armes
grâce à une armée révolutionnaire ce
pays qui doit traquer les ennemis
intérieurs parce qu'il reste ce sont les
problèmes de la sortie de remplir il
reste toutes ces minorités qui ne
correspondent pas au modèle turc et
sunnites ça s'appelle les arméniens les
grecs les juifs il s'appelle aussi
évidemment les cures les alevis qui sont
des musulmans et qui ne sont pas des
musulmans orthodoxes lesquels depuis un
siècle puisque cette république a
maintenant un tir une existence non pas
en fait
2e même d'existence légale n'est ce pas
ennemis intérieurs ennemi extérieur ces
grandes puissances
londres paris en 1920 mais aujourd'hui
évidemment retour téhéran washington qui
donne l'impression à ce peuple que en
fait on ne veut pas de lui qui lui a
rogné en quelque sorte les ailes tout ça
ça rentre la turquie et ça explique que
le gros moteur turc c'est celui d'une
fabrique nationalistes de la création en
quelque sorte d'un citoyen modèle d'un
citoyen qui serait ethniquement pur turc
qui serait religieusement pur musulmans
sunnites
un pays enfin unifier un pays qui ne
seraient plus traversée par ses courants
marins qui viennent de l'histoire
profonde et qui pourrait le déstabiliser
un pays qui a enfin retrouvé le sens sa
fierté notion très importante de son
mandat de son indépendance est un pays
qui pourrait enfin réaffirmé ses
prétentions naturel parce que ce pays il
malgré tout que l'héritier d'un des plus
grands empires que le monde ait connu un
empire qui allait de sarajevo à lui et
qui descendait jusqu'à la mecque qui
remontaient jusqu'à la mer caspienne et
en fait nous ne comprenons rien la
turquie parce que nous avons en quelque
sorte une bonne et une mauvaise turquie
alors la bonne pour nous c'est très
facilement celle d'atatürk
parce que la turquie européaniser la
turquie occidentalisé et puis la
mauvaise évidemment dans leur
présentation française s'est facilement
cdr dogan parce que c'est la turquie
islamique disait la mise et religieuses
traditionnelles et donc nous opposons en
quelques sortes le révolutionnaire kemal
qui est un réformiste qui un
progressiste à erdogan qui serait lui en
quelque sorte un réactionnaire religieux
fondamentalistes mais en fait il n'ya
pas de turquie il y à une seule et main
turquie qui depuis un siècle cherche en
fait asseoir une identité incertaine et
je dirais aujourd'hui alors qu'elle a
récupéré en quelque sorte sa force
vitale
elle nous fait cherche à nous faire peur
en quelque sorte parce qu'un a peur elle
même elle a peur de son absence de
fondation de son absence de fondement
elle a peur parce qu'elle pratique une
sorte de fuite en avant et en fait
lorsqu'on regarde de très près il s'agit
pas d'opposer atatürk erdogan
atatürk pour aller très vite a
nationalisé des slams erdogan lui
l'islamisme la nation et on est à la
recherche véritablement de 7 en quelque
sorte sorti de ce tunnel originel de
cette angoisse originel donc d'un côté
ils ont les mains ennemies atatürk mène
des campagnes terrible de bombardements
contre les kurdes
entre mine dès 1923 jusqu'en 1928 1930
lesparre et erdogan se retrouve à
chasser les turcs et kurdes aujourd'hui
en syrie et en irak
atatürk réclamé à londres et à paris
d'avoir à led et mossoul qui
considéraient comme des villes qui
devait être turc aujourd'hui
erdogan est aux portes de l est est de
mossoul atatürk a pris le sandjak
d'alexandrette thonon comme chez tintin
c'est la bordure le coût de la
méditerranée c'est antioche qui étaient
mille arabes les français nous leur
apprenons dans la grandeur nature qui ce
territoire qui était surtout syrien
alaouite en 1938 en espérant que la
turquie serait avec nous contre
l'allemagne
elle a été très tardivement en 1945 mais
déjà atatürk et chypre oui et entre les
gares de gaz rue et le retour en
méditerranée vous l'avez vu cet été où
la france est intervenue auprès de la
grèce au sujet des îles de la mer egée
et surtout évidemment des grandes
réserves de gaz qui lient à sur les
codes qui partent de libye passe par
l'egypte israël et arrive à chypre dont
vous voyez bien que en fait
structurellement on est dans les mêmes
attitudes si ce n'est que c'est le
carburant qui a changé c'est pas la
turquie qui a changé c'est monde hier à
cette idéologie progressiste qui faisait
en fait
l'horizon des peuples en voie de
formation
qui voulaient se créer des temps
réalisation est aujourd'hui c'est la
religion mais vous avez en fait une
symétrie
mais jean françois colosimo quand on lit
votre livre on a l'impression que ça
remonte encore bien plus loin ça remonte
à mai m 2 le conquérant de
constantinople qu'il va leur bâti qui
sera rebaptisée istanbul
et là on se dit mais m 2 qui à 20 ans 14
153 seulement le magnifique qui va
donner à l'empiré ottoman son ampleur
extraordinaire atatürk eux
herdman aujourd'hui même combat ça
paraît un peu facile
c'est pas le combat d'abord parce que
mehmet est un véritable concurrent
espoir et soliman l'a véritablement
façonner un des plus grands empires
on n'est plus dans un cadre intérieur
aujourd'hui on est plus de dons le cadre
d'un état nation trois permanences de
construction et de reconstruction parce
qu'il a du mal à trouver en fait son
contour cet état nation et sa stabilité
pour mémoire il y a eu surtout trois
putschs militaires dramatique entre 1960
et 1980 il y en a eu deux autres ensuite
dont le dernier je suis de 2015 a permis
à erdogan d'accéder aux plats pouvoir
n'est ce pas vous voyez un pays qui a à
peu près 90 ans d'existence et qui a
connu cinq putsch militaire ça c'est
pour le sabre et dans l'autre côté ce
pays s'est développée aussi sur
l'adhésion à l'islam depuis les ottomans
ça c'est plutôt la mosquée à la caserne
et c'est le pouvoir des oulémas n'est ce
pas
et donc vous avez ce rapport très fort
finalement entre le pouvoir religieux le
pouvoir militaire
c'est toute l'histoire la turquie
regardez les images défiler depuis 1923
voyez kemal qui est en général
victorieux de faire un camp militaire
lors de la première guerre mondiale
et voyez aujourd'hui erdogan en train de
prier à la mosquée est reprise dans
sainte-sophie qu'il a réouvert à la
prière coranique
alors que la turquie devait faire mumuse
et vous avez ces deux équilibre ces
déséquilibres qui sont faites un
déséquilibre permanent proviennent
effectivement vous avez raison de l'
empire ottoman
parce que l'empiré ottoman c'est quoi
cet impact le peuple turc qui est un
peuple nomade a maintenu la conquête
c'est l'héritage d'un empire
administratif héritage administratif
héritage esthétique héritage
architectural et les tâches politiques
c'est l' empire byzantin qui n'est pas
musulman et c'est évidemment l'héritage
aussi
de la profonde du profond désir de la
profonde obsession depuis le prophète de
conquérir constantinople qui la nouvelle
rome et de conquérir cette sophie qui
est alors le plus grand sanctuaire
religieux du monde entier
lorsque mes mecs entre dans
sainte-sophie
n'est ce pas eh bien ils marquent cette
conquête il monte sur l'autel de sainte
sophie le piétine non pas à la manière
des conquérants musulmans à la manière
des césars romain lorsqu'il prenait une
ville sous le paganisme pour montrer que
les lieux de la ville étaient éteints
qu'un nouveau dieu devait prendre la
place or royer erdogan
il a créé un et - mondial en annulant le
statut de musée de sainte sophie y avait
pas vraiment besoin de ça il ya trois
mille mosquées à istanbul sunnites tout
à fait régulière est bien plus que sa
fille a est bien plus belle que sa fille
ont été formés par d'horribles contre
forces sismiques dans les mosquées des
jeunes sont cent fois plus belle que ça
ne se fit ou la mosquée bleue qui est
une pâle imitation raufast à détails et
je vois que comme moi vous connaissez
bien istanbul son histoire et que vous
et l'istanbul ce que j'aime aussi cette
ville de si magnifiques si hospitalière
donc par rapport à ça je dis c'est très
simple ce jour là c'est le patron de
direct qui fait le prêche le cerveau le
patron de diane est c'est quoi le
dialecte
c'est un organisme créé par mustafa
kemal pour contrôler l'état parce que la
laïcité chez mustapha kemal ça veut dire
que l'islam est soumis à des tas ça veut
pas dire la laïcité au sens français et
donc le patron de l'adn est aujourd'hui
lé annette emploie 120 mille
fonctionnaires
c'est le ministère des cultes et un
budget de 3 milliards d'euros
on est un peu la proportion peu de
ministères en france en ce niveau là
cependant le patron indiens natifs et le
sermon rond il le fait avec un turban et
à sabre à la main c'est le sabre du
conquérant c'est le sabre de 20 mètres
et ne commente pas le coran c'est pas un
cerveau
musulmans coranique important sur la
spiritualité de l'islam ou sur les
prescriptions de l'islam
il parle de la conquête il parle d'un
conquête de mme et m il parle des
conquêtes de l'empiré ottoman il parle
de l'esprit de la conquête
il dit que c'est un jour de reconquête
parce que enfin 5 sophie est rendu alors
à quoi au culte musulman oui mais est
rendu en fait à quoi au culte de la
turquie que la turquie grand à la
turquie qui est inculte
encore une fois c'est le mot de conquête
alors on revient d'ailleurs que le
président erdogan par rapport à ta turc
est à turquie était très limitée n'est
ce pas parce que déjà il avait reconquis
les territoires que les alliés voulaient
lui enlever les alliés avaient prévu une
grande arménie il est prévu un kurdistan
toutes ces choses qui ont disparu pour
former la turquie actuelle parce qu'il a
été vainqueur militairement grande à
coeur à côté de ça donc il pouvait plus
faire grand chose puisqu'il est d'aller
au maximum en quelque sorte de ses
prétentions territoriales dans une
époque en plus chamboulés par la montée
des totalitarismes
mais rappelez-vous kata turc c'est plus
contemporain de mussolini et de staline
qui niait le contemporain d'un récit de
briand et du président wilson voyait à
c'est un projet démiurgique qu'il à
faire changer un pays
du jour au lendemain tout change les
pois les mesures le calendrier
l'habillement l'alphabet tout lrp anisé
véritablement en trois ans c'est une
marche forcée vers une transformation
dont évidemment on voit aujourd'hui
aussi le contre effet puisqu'il ya une
forme de négation de l'identité
mais par rapport à ça donc atatürk
il est au maximum ses prétentions
erdogan ne n'est pas parce que nous
sommes dans un grand roman en fait de
désordre mondial et voyez tout de même
je veux dire les troupes turques sont
aujourd'hui au nord de la syrie et de
l'irak pour contrôler le problème cure
pour empêcher la jonction des kurdes de
syrie d'irak les les kurdes de turquie
monsieur erdogan et dans la mer egée par
wi fi des forages dans des eaux
territoriales qui sont pas les siennes
ça émeut les grecs la france dépêche
elle aussi des vaisseaux de guerre
monsieur erdogan est présent en libye où
il joue le gouvernement provisoire
libyen qui est plutôt de tendance frères
musulmans donc plutôt étrange détruisant
conduise la liste contre le général
akhtar qui est soutenue par la france et
la russie
et grâce à l'apport de monsieur erdogan
le gouvernement provisoire vraiment mais
une déculottée militaires aux généraux
du maréchal haftar aujourd'hui les
présents en azerbaïdjan il a déplacé des
mercenaires en azerbaïdjan lorsque
l'azerbaïdjan a décidé à de conquérir le
karabagh et il l'a aussi soutenu
l'effort de guerre à azéri avec
évidemment des moyens technologiques
très avancées mais aussi des troupes
donc c'est bien cet homme qui inquiète
tout de même la communauté
internationale qui traite madame merkel
de nazis qui conseille au président
macron d'aller se faire soigner un
hôpital psychiatrique qui est capable
aussi à la suite de la mort tragique de
samuel bâti de réveiller l'international
des frères musulmans dont il est en
quelque sorte le patron parce que
monsieur erdogan n'est plus un frère
musulman qu'un musulman d'options dans
l'islam qui est très très forte et ce
sont tous ces groupes qui ont pratiqué
l'autodafé des portraits de macron qui
ont constitué la france qui ont bréville
d'un profond théâtralement c'est son
international sont komintern à lui n'est
ce pas et qui dépasse de loin derrière
les anciennes frontières de l'empiré
ottoman donc on va faire véritablement
il faut le dire un véritable politique
pied une politique extrêmement agressive
mais qui pour l'instant une politique
gagnante personnes pensent avoir été en
même temps on peut comprendre la
nostalgie d'une puissance perdue
il n'est pas le seul
dogen lcd tout le monde en ce moment à
l'air d'y céder y compris bon nombre de
français d'ailleurs mais si l'on vous
écoute bien l'ambition belliciste du
président aux turcs
elles se manifestent contre les turcs
mais aussi contre les arabes notamment
contre l'arabie saoudite contre les
contre les grecs et les arméniens mais
aussi contre les européens elle elle va
contrôler russell va contre les iraniens
à un moment il va bien falloir qu'ils se
tapent aussi les chinois parce qu'ils
sont pas loin et puis à la fin j'imagine
qu'il y aura grand duel contre les états
unis
mais vous comprenez bien que ça ne peut
pas aller très loin
ses seuls alliés dans l'histoire c'est
le qatar et vraisemblement l'azerbaïdjan
parce qu il vient d aider mais à part ça
c'est un état extrêmement isolées la
turquie aujourd'hui elle y ait du monde
votre cas lié avec personne parce qu'il
faut bien rappeler que l'état liées et
de la france et des états unis et de la
grèce dans l'otan bien sûr le nord de la
turquie aujourd'hui et dans l'otan et
achètent des armes à la russie qui est
des nuits des signes et de l'otan nous
ne connais pas une contradiction près si
vous voulez alors c'est pour ça qu'elle
ne sert pas elle est très loin que la
turquie belliciste soit forte de nos
faiblesses
c'était dix ans n'est ce pas alors
évidemment monsieur erdogan et au four
la cape et son parti profite évidemment
encore une fois je vais ni d'un fort d
ordre mondial cela dit le cas même
d'étonnantes ressources il faut les lui
reconnaître quand monsieur erdogan fait
du poutine avec poutine lorsqu'il se
prend lui même l'anr poutine qui a mis
un peu de temps à réagir
alors que la turquie avancé dans son pré
carré le caucase et après carré que la
russie avait prise après carré que la
russie avait pris des trois siècles plus
tôt à l' empire ottoman envoyé le
caucase l'humain vous avez raison de
mentionner
shi veut dire pourquoi l'azerbaïdjan
parce que évidemment maintenant c'est
gagner la mer caspienne
mais après les abeilles de gens il ya
les autres républiques turcophones
c'est pour ça que ce n'est pas que les
affaires religieuses c'est aussi une
affaire aussi un signe linguistique et
ses répliques turcophones pour l'instant
qu'il existe en ouzbékistan etc
c'est une plateforme pour rejoindre les
ouïghoure de chine qui ont la partie et
j'ai encore d'être à la fois musulmans
et turcophones et qui sont réellement
persécuté par le pouvoir chinois
il n'y a pas de contestation là dessus
n'est ce pas mais voyez que les intérêts
tout de même d'ankara son taux d intérêt
qui mixtent le caractère national et le
caractère religieux
c'est ça la singularité propres alors
évidemment monsieur train peut adorer
les manières de monsieur erdogan
ça sera sûrement pas le cas de joe biden
mais il est vrai aussi que l'amérique a
des intérêts cruciaux stratégique en
turquie la fameuse base d'in chimique
qui est la vraie base du clair les états
unis ont des états unis à partir de
laquelle les états unis peuvent viser
moscou pékin téhéran et damas bad
ça c'est un rapport très fort la même
manière que c'est sûr toujours les états
unis qui ont voulu que la turquie soit
dans le roi parce qu'il fallait qu'elle
soit dans l'otan dès l'époque de la
guerre froide où la turquie était la
sentinelle de l'occident face au monde
soviétique
bien sûr mais voyez quand même temps
nous sommes engagés avec monsieur
erdogan dans une affaire par heureuse
qui s'est le plus grand puisque monsieur
erdogan effectivement reçu sur son
territoire deux trois questions de
migrants qu'il retient si nous payons
pour qu'il retienne ne devons payer avec
de l'argent deux fois 3 milliards
d'euros du groupe était aussi avec des
visas nous avons payé avec des
aménagements etc etc etc
et là il a une arme formidable parce que
l'europe est totalement désunis sur
cette question a évidemment est de votre
côté en même temps la même turquie qui
nous dit vous devez payer pour les
migrants pour guy nzouba chez vous
considère que ses propres émigré en
europe demeurent ses ressortissants ces
sujets c'est la fin
déclaration de monsieur erdogan à
cologne en 2003 lorsqu'il est dit que
l'assimilation était un crime contre
l'humanité d'envoyer qui a tout de même
une singularité
cette singularité n'empêche pas que la
turquie soit un grand pays que les turcs
soit un grand peuple
au contraire et puis nous aimons tout
une turquie donc que nous aimons et dont
nous raffolons parents pensons
évidemment à celle de groix d'un manque
le prix nobel de littérature
pensons à celle de churn l'onda le grand
documentariste la spa et et journalistes
pensons à celle de fazil say immense
pianiste pensons à celle de asli erdogan
c'est un homonyme
c'est une romancière et tous ces gens
aujourd'hui vivent en exil
ils vivent en exil c'est pas nouveau
mais la répression des généraux en 1981
était aussi cruel pour les milieux
intellectuels artistiques médiatique que
celle de 2015
donc c'est pas nouveau la c5 je dis moi
c'est qu'elle peut de choses nouvelles
au fond mais voyez que dans cette
turquie là nous l'aimons et c'est aux
turcs évidemment de régler leur avenir
aujourd'hui le pouvoir tient rares cas
parce que c'est l'union des islamistes
et des hyper nationaliste voilà est-ce
que c'est le bon avenir pour les turcs
il ya tout lieu d'ondés et il est
évident que encore une fois il s'agit
surtout de refuser cette logique de
guerre ou d'affrontement ce n'est pas
notre relation avec les turcs humains et
et pour la dépasser il faut malgré tout
on retrouve un peu d'ordre international
de quel ordre international
aujourd'hui n'est pas simplement
désormais par lui-même mais voir un
joueur extraordinaire
je veux dire véritablement mise et le
maximum sur la table et c'est monsieur
erdogan mais en serait il est le bon
successeur de monsieur atatürk
contrairement à ce que nous nous croyons
voilà il nous reste une minute avant la
avant la pause jean-françois que le 6 mo
il n'y a pas que les turcs en exil il y
a aussi parlé d'istanbul c'est une ville
effectivement que j'aime profondément
une de mes villes préférées dans le
monde
les habitants d'istanbul
me paraissent pas l'idée ni tous
appartenir à l'extrême droite
nationaliste ni tous être des fanatiques
religieux est une ville extrêmement
accueillante extrêmement ouverte et
extrêmement tolérant en tout cas dans
l'image que je m'en fais c'est ça ne
cède en paix voilà le peuple turc que
j'imagine et très bigarré lui même très
libère absolument évidemment il s'agit
pas d'être manichéen et moi aussi j'aime
beaucoup istanbul mais voyez qu'istanbul
qui héritière de constantinople qui
attire aussi de la stamboul très
cosmopolite de pierre loti qui est une
ville carrefour des mondes est ouest
occident orient
cette ville magnifique elle a eu un sip
tayyip erdogan comme air sur un
programme anti-corruption pour avant
qu'il ne devienne premier ministre puis
président aujourd'hui elle s'est donnée
comme maire un opposant de monsieur
erdogan la même manière qu ankara qui
est l'autre capitale la capitale moderne
que la brasilia turc
ces données elles aussi un maire qui est
un opposant donc bien entendu il ya une
vitalité démocratique extraordinaire
dans le peuple turc et dire le contraire
serait non seulement faux mais tout à
fait je dirais malvenue le sabre et et
le turban c'est le titre du nouveau
livre de jean françois colossimo qui
vient de paraître aux éditions du cerf
ont fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après avec alain baraton
[Musique]
alain baraton vous êtes jardinier en
chef du château de versailles et
maintenant du domaine de marly
c'est un peu un must à dans votre
profession difficile de faire mieux
c'est donc à vous qu'il est revenu
décrire le dictionnaire amoureux des
jardins qui ressort aujourd'hui en
version illustrée aux éditions plon et
grün
commençons par le le jardin à la
française puisqu'il en a un très beau
juste derrière vous on le voit c'est
celui du château de versailles
mais on va voir également bagatelle on
va voir le château du champ de bataille
shanty chenonceau autant de magnifiques
exemples de jardin à la française qui
figure dans votre livre est ce que ça
n'est pas le contraire de la nature
m'écoutais je pense à notre conversation
avec jean françois collet simon où l'on
parlait du pouvoir
j'en à la française cet argent là de
pouvoir
c'est un jardin d'autorité à versailles
ce genre là n'avaient pas pour objet de
faire plaisir à louis xiv ou de groupe
qu'ils puissent montrer à quelques
marquise la floraison de telle ou telle
plante rats c'était l'un de ces plaisirs
mais ce n'était pas le principal sera la
française c'est pour montrer à ces
sujets à l'humanité toute entière de la
nature vous obéit
c'est une manière d'avoir la même là la
nature chez soi louis xiv ne peut pas
gouverner le monde
alors il faut entendre que le monde
entier soit vérifiable l'orangerie les
ménageries il ya les actes ayant candau
au bien de montrer que averse a été
partout oui 14 seront via la nature les
aubes et donc effectivement pour
répondre à votre question
j'en à la française c'est peut-être pas
l'une une attaque sur la nature c'est
vraiment un endroit où c'est le jardin
où la nature est accompagnée où elle est
honnête domestique et où elle est aux
ordres d'un charnier où d'un manager
alors c'est pas très naturel peut-être
mais ce que l'on sait moins c'est que
quand louis xiv fait qu'on sera
versailles pour que son environnement ne
soit pas dénaturé justement il força de
préserver les forêts giboyeuses de la
région donc le jardin à la française
à côté landes nature et l'environnement
de lui et naturel
on le voit très bien là c'est chez nous
au je crois qu'ils
alors non je tenais pétoncles ces
chantiers qu est un château voulue par
par le grand condé c'est le nôtre lui
aussi qui a créé ce jardin ce qui est
extraordinaire dans ce jardin de pouvoir
c'est que l'on utilise la nature ou la
transformer et pour qu'elle vous flatte
ce qui est extraordinaire dans ce japon
qui était d'ailleurs le préféré attendre
le nom qu on croit toujours que c'est
vers ces erreurs jean ma préférée dans
de le nôtre c'est celui que nous voyons
ces chantiers quand vous arrivez dé
traverser une forêt merveilleuse vous
aimez et vous avez le sentiment d'une
perspective absolument parfaite faut il
joue des perspectives
il s'en amuse pour donner de l'égalité
loud and a pas c'est aussi ça genre un
française la modification de l'espace se
jouer de la nature
justement on va voir le nôtre est ce que
est ce que ça n'est pas le jardinier en
tant que tyran et vous même aujourd'hui
qui est son successeur à versailles
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas obligé de
d'agir en tirant alors les mêmes les
modes ont changé bien évidemment depuis
de là je ne me considère pas vraiment
comme le successeur d'andré le nombre
dépassait de prétention simplement l'un
de ceux qui a pour mission de veiller à
ce que son héritage soit entretenu le
nôtre effectivement tyranniser la nature
incontestablement et la domestique et
peut-être mais la contraignait
aujourd'hui nous continuons d'entretien
ce genre n'a voulu par louis xiv mais
nous avons décidé de changer quelques
pratiques
les hommes ne sont plus tabous rideau
comme il l'était autrefois la taille est
beaucoup plus douce
on a permis l'accès libre à certaines
pelouses et n'oubliez pas non plus qu'il
ya avec ça un autre jardin le jardin de
voulue par marie antoinette un espace de
liberté où celles contraintes jalala
française imposé par le nôtre est bien
être contrebalancé avec ce jardin
champêtre voulu par la reine qui lui se
veut totalement un espace de liberté
alors il ya les jardins à la française
ya le jardin anglais qu'on oppose
toujours au jardin à la française
et puis elle et les jardins arabe et
dans votre dans votre livre figure les
jardins de l'alcazar à séville que vous
aimez beaucoup alors c'est pourtant
postérieure à la roque wista des rois
catholiques espagnols mais on a dix ans
gardez l'esprit du dujardin arabe qu'est
ce qui le caractérise le jardin arabe
pour vous le gendarme je préférais
peut-être les taux même le jardin de
l'islam est à mes yeux le plus beau
jardin c'est un mal acquis et conçu avec
subtilité où tous les sens sont
accaparés il y à la vue des les vidéos
mais les lotos rats et des senteurs
merveilleuse ces arbres qui se sentent
la flore danger c'est une merveille mais
ce sont des jardins qui sont si précieux
ont l'ayant souvent qu'ils étaient
dessinés autrefois sur les tapis persan
et oui le tapis persans représente un
jardin ce qui permettait aux
propriétaires data pitt offrir alors là
on offrait un jardin comme cadeau je
trouve ça merveilleux et ce sont
également des lieux d'une perfection
absolument extraordinaire si parfait que
quand on venait dans ce jardin quand on
y était invité on se devait même de
parler à moi j'allais dire feu très doux
l'expression jardin secret car quand on
quand on venait dans ce genre là c'était
que vraiment on était bien vu par le
propriétaire
donc tout ce qui les gêne pas arabe
jarre la de l'islam
ce sont des gens là qui sont conçus avec
subtilité avec intelligence l'eau est
toujours au centre du jardin sur l'eau
source de vie et bien souvent les quatre
fleuves du paradis c'est quelque chose
de merveilleux
ce son jeu je ne devrais pas vous le
dire mais qu'ils soient versées mais
vraiment les plus beaux jardins du monde
alors les il ya des très beaux
alignements de platanes dans votre livre
on va on va le voir tout de suite alors
ses taux au bord d'une rivière au lieu
d'être une bombe au bord d'une route
mais on se souvient que la france a
connu des alignements de platanes tel
que celui ci
le long de toutes les routes nationales
et ça a causé la mort de deux centaines
et voire de milliers d'automobilistes
est ce que ça valait le coup je ne suis
pas sûr que ces arbres et causé la mort
ils sont malheureusement quand considéré
comme objet que l'on percute
mais il ya certainement eu autant
d'accidents dans des ravages dans des
virages malice galets pour défaut de
signalisation césar au contraire je ne
veux pas vous contredire
d'après une étude anglaise ont tendance
même
en sorte que le l'automobiliste et envie
de ralentir
toujours est il que ces arbres qui
autrefois on le sait trop peu n'était
pas mise pour permettre aux pèlerins de
se promener à londres donc mais
d'empêcher le paysan d'agrandir
centaines s'étaient par le l'abandon
comme été les arbres ce qui explique
pourquoi dans les campagnes il y avait
des arbres
et bien c'est merveilleux fait un peu
partie de notre de notre patrimoine le
président au champion pedro lui même
pourtant amateur de voitures je croyais
qu'ils roulent en porsche avait lu une
lettre merveilleuse où il demande à son
premier ministre de l'époque de cesser
l'abattage le long des routes qui pour
lui était une atteinte grave à la beauté
du pays qui était le sien je voulais
photo effectivement une photo du canal
du midi se prend une photo polémique
je voulais vraiment une photo en courbe
comme quoi un alignement peut-être cours
mais l'occasion de rappeler que ces
armes sont merveilleux ils sont d'une
beauté incroyable est que ces arbres ne
sont pas que des éléments de poids aux
deux sèvres
ce soit les témoins vivants tu as passé
proche ou lointain ce sont des souvenirs
l'arbre est quelque chose de merveilleux
un jardin sans arbre n'est pas vraiment
un jardin le genre la lame
c'est le temps le temps qui passe d'où
cette photo et mon obligation mentale à
m dont ce livre consacré au jardin des
âmes
il ya des magnifiques photos d'arbres
est ce que les les arbres sont beaux on
est tous d'accord est ce qu'ils sont
intelligents
c'est devenu une espèce de grande
question à aujourd'hui après les animaux
les arbres je le crois de plus en plus
j'ai lu il n'ya pas longtemps dans une
étude par exemple que les enfants
dormaient les boulots il a été constaté
que la nuit avec tendance d'avoir une
certaine flexibilité à l'extrémité des
rameaux un peu comme votre scène
elle-même vit avec moins de pression
dans les vaisseaux il en serait de même
pour les arbres on sait que les offres
sont capables avec certaines formes bien
sûr de communiquer entre eux de
s'échanger des informations
on sait qu'il y aurait même mal
maintenant des armes capables de
transmettre
déjà les amm sont capables de percevoir
leur environnement cc c'est une chose
reconnu donc oui je pense que les armes
sont intelligents ils
développement est pas là mais
l'intelligence que la vôtre ou la mienne
mais elles sont capables de s'inscrire
dans une dans une forme d'intelligence
on voit à l'image on peut déconner on
doit avoir des séquoias bien le séquoia
a quand même eu l'idée de se débarrasser
des bons jeux les plus basses pour
éviter qu'ils de souffle dans des
incendies de forêt le séquoia a été
capable de se produire une écorce
spongieuse parce que justement il vit
dans les endroits où les incendies sont
fréquents
donc il ya une adaptation mais je
m'étonne d'ailleurs pour les plantes on
parle d'adaptation pour les éléments ont
parlé d'un instant pour les hommes on
parle d'intelligence de temps en temps
je me demande je ne dormirai pas
inversion dans la bon trois catégories
je viens de citer
pourquoi est ce que votre saison
préférée et l'automne vous l'aviez déjà
dit dans un livre précédent vous en avez
écrit de nombreux vous leur dites dans
ce dictionnaire
pourquoi l'automne il ya deux manières
d'apprécier l'automne
la première ma qualité de jardinier le
jeune en automne les parterres ont été
fleuries ils vont être arrachés
la saison est terminée nous sommes un
peu comme des comédiens qui venons de
jouer une pièce sur une semaine
nous pouvons saluer le public en
espérant bien sûr que le spectacle a été
une réussite donc l'automne c'est la fin
de l' angoisse
l'automne c'est la fin des travaux
qu'ils ne peuvent pas être remis au
lendemain
au printemps une tombe qui n'est pas
effectuée le lundi le mercredi nous
faudra beaucoup plus de temps car entre
temps et laura pous mais le town on peut
enfin souffler beaucoup de travail mais
on peut souffler plus l'automne et les
suivis par l'hiver les vertes seul
moment où enfin on peut être pris par la
neige par le froid on peut vraiment
réfléchir tranquillement et ne pas être
trop bousculés donc j'aime le fun parce
que la nature et le jardinier ont le
temps de penser au futur
j'aime aussi l'automne pour les couleurs
quand tu vois les teintes que les ars
sont capables de prendre quand on voit
c'est jaune c'est rouge et c'est orange
qui peut leur de jardin je trouve ça
merveilleux et vous me demandiez à
l'instant si les armes étaient
intelligents en bas là aussi j'en
profite pour vous rappeler que si les
arbres perdent leurs feuilles à
l'automne
c'est pour éviter d'avoir à puiser
l'eau en hiver au risque de pablo poids
si l'eau est gelée dans la terre c'est
une forme d'intelligence de n'être
capable d'anticiper le froid de semaine
en dormance et d'attendre le printemps
pour revivre les les jardins suspendus
de babylone
on va en voir une une reconstitution
bien entendu on en a fait beaucoup au
19e siècle
est-ce qu'ils ont existé et d'ailleurs
c'est très drôle quand on voit cette
reconstitution c'est ce que ça ça ça
ressemble beaucoup aux architecture
futuriste où on voit des limites et que
de plus en plus avec beaucoup beaucoup
de verdure
mais est-ce qu'ils ont existé les
jardins suspendus de babylone et à
quantité de débat à ce sujet certains
vont prétendre que oui d'autres que non
des archéologues aurait même retrouvé
leurs traces du côté de la syrie ce
genre de choses donc je suis incapable
de vous dire s'ils ont véritablement
existe ou pas ce que je sais c'est qu'il
serait donné le fait que nabuchodonosor
a voulu offrir à son épouse desjardins
pour lui rappeler large où elle est née
donc le plus beau jardin à l'origine est
un cadeau fait une femme je trouve ça
extraordinaire
j'ai également beaucoup apprécié j'ai
rencontré ya pas longtemps
l'ambassadeur dû royaume du bahreïn pied
venus et sinem à versailles
il ya au milieu du désert de bahreïn un
arbre une sorte d'acacia qui vit au
milieu d'eux au milieu de rien et je lui
disais mais comment cet arbre at il fait
pour naître ici
et comment fêter pour puiser de l'eau il
m'a dit qu'il pensait lui qu'il était le
survivant jardin de l'éden donc le
jardin d'éden aurait d'après certaines
personnes étaient localisés dans le
golfe dans la péninsule arabique
de par la présence d'anna vivrait encore
du fait que autrefois c'était un jardin
qu'il était très très très fin très très
très très arrosée alors justement
passons au jardin d'éden puisqu'il ya
aussi un tableau qui représente le
jardin d'éden
dans ce dictionnaire amoureux illustré
desjardins vous dites que les pommes
vraisemblablement n'existait pas en tout
cas ne ressemblait pas à l'idée qu'on se
fait des pommes au moment où
hypothétiquement adam et eve il vivait
bah oui tout à fait les pommes ont été
des fruits travail et qui à l'autre fois
la grosseur d'une cerise donc déjà
l'image de la pomme permet justement aux
deux dates de contredire quelque peu la
version biblique et je reviens à votre
question
le jardin de l'éden existe-t-il vraiment
alors parlons justement de celui ci
c'est m à croquer une pomme
c'est donc que le pommier avait aînés là
où il y avait je madeleine or il s'avère
que le pommier sur les toujours est
originaire du kasaï du kazakh ce
qu'entend pardonnez moi donc comme peu
de temps en temps il ya quelque chose
qui ne vont pas tous le prétendent que
ce n'était pas une pom pom avec lui mais
une figue
certains pensent même à une banane
qu'après je ne sais pas toujours est il
que ce jardin de l'éden a inspiré tous
les grands auteurs brugel a fait des
tableaux assure merveilleux francis
bacon a écrit des textes absolument
sublime alors le jardin de l'éden l'oci
a t as détesté
je ne sais pas mais toujours est il que
le pommier effectivement si on disait
des pommes celle ci avait essais
scientifiques
la grosse cerise ouais c'est intéressant
mais dans le jardin d'éden on pense
toujours à la pomme mais on imaginait
d'ailleurs ce tableau montre bien c'est
un foisonnement c'est giboyeux c'était
absolument extraordinaire vous
l'imaginez comment vous le jardin d'éden
s'il existait ben je l'imaginais un
petit peu un petit peu comme le lab je
vous parlais twitter de l'ordre du
bahreïn j'imagine un très grand espace
justement paisible où chaque animal par
exemple aurait son territoire à lui et
ne vivrait pas ne supporterait pas
commander à la présence d'un autre
animal
ça me rappelle parfois les gens là
aujourd'hui je n'en prennent pas dans
mon livre c'est la mode des hôtels à
insectes tout cette mode extraordinaire
comme si les insectes accepter de vivre
ensemble dans le même hôtel
même chose en tout est merveilleux là on
voit donc les animaux domestiques comme
un cheval en photo on y voit des
hippopotames des lions des tirs tous les
continents sont représentés au même
endroit apparemment la température ou la
froidure de sang bleu jaune et personne
dans jeanne horrible le doute sur
l'existence même est du jardin d'éden et
même de dieu pour ne rien vous cacher et
jardin italien alors lui il existe
d'après d'après ce que vous dites
parce que souvent on a dit que jardin à
la française en fête venait d'italie le
jardin italien se serait celui que j'ai
derrière moi
quelle est sa caractéristique est est-ce
qu'il s'agit bien d'un jardin dit et
italiens avaient complètement mais le
jardin italien
c'est vraiment le journal italien c'est
vraiment le jardin qui a été à l'origine
même de versailles les premiers à avoir
découvert les jardins tallien à l'époque
de françois 1er
on trouvait déjà extraordinaire où les
dieux étaient le refi alors on les a
introduits en france et bien sûr en
france on est toujours mieux que les
autres je le dis entre guillemets bien
sûr on a agrandi les perspectives on à
alain el-adli on a créé des états on a
multiplié par 10 ou par balle les
surfaces quand vous prenez l'exemple de
versailles versailles c'est en fait un
jardin est allé les premiers est venu
mettre en hausse juin étaient les frères
français il était d'italiens mais quand
on voit même la stature de versailles
c'est l'étaler dans toute sa splendeur
donc oui j'en la française est née du
jardin italien parce que le chalet est
allé c'est l'essence même de ce jardin
où l'on a su associer avec une justesse
incroyable l'eau la statue est et le
végétal
oui c'est ça qui est frappant quand on
voit ici c'est la statuaire évidemment
qui nous rappelle les fontaines du
bernin à rome et tout c'est tous ces
bassins qui caractérise la ville de rome
ça c'est typiquement italien jamais les
français n'aurait l'idée de faire
quelque chose de similaire
il aurait peut-être eu l'idée donc les
que je vous demanderai à quel homme dans
quel endroit le premier à avoir eu
l'idée d'installer ce type de foutaises
c'est à versailles c'est andré le nôtre
c'est jacques moley
c'est jacques androuet du cerceau ce
sont des architectes qui était imprégné
de l'italie la seule fois que andré le
nôtre a quitté la france c'est pour se
rendre en italie ne sait vraiment
directement inspiré déjà avant le jardin
à la française tout était posé calculer
mais est vite passé mouvement taux y
avait pas cette sonde 7
les stèles statues étaient à l'intérieur
du bâtiment
c'est louis xiv qu'elle eut l'idée de
permettre aux visiteurs de découvrir des
jardins
quand vous allez à versailles et que
vous découvrez les bains d'apollon qui
sont à mes yeux elle est la plus belle
des statuts et on est dans l'esprit
italien donc effectivement le genre à
étaler un a inspiré quantité de jardin
des jardins à la française mais aussi
des jardins un petit peu particulier
comme prénom + jardins de marqueyssac
ils sont des jardins situés sur une
toile avec des pluies mais ce que je
n'avais je n'avais évidemment repérer
les jardins de marqueyssac que je ne
connaissais pas que j'ai découvert grade
grâce à votre vives qui est absolument
magnifique on va là on va le voir tout
de suite et ça c'est un jardin italien
non cet argent là on va dire qu'il n'a
pas incité particulier mais qui a été
fait par un zouave pontifical un homme
qui était militaire dans les armées du
vatican et il découvre le style italien
il vient en france et la chaîne cette
propriété située sur un promontoire au
jeu il construit parquet c'est donc ce
n'est pas un jardin italien
mais ces jardins directement inspiré
jean l'italien de par le bruit qui est
vraiment typique des jardins ou de
désalpe on voit les pas quand vous voyez
les peindre c'est bien sûr à la ville de
rome puisque ces mêmes l'emblème de la
ville
donc ces jardins ne sont pas en italie 1
mais vraiment inspiré de l'été
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont de
particulier c'est ils sont organiques
c'est ça qui nous frappe placée donc ça
nous semble très moderne
il date de quand à l'origine alors ce
sont des jardins qui ont été recréés au
design on va dire à la fin du 19e siècle
se sent bien qu'ils ne sont pas très
ancien mais marqueyssac étant là qui
nomine pratiquement aucune règle c'est
un râle un spectacle c'est un jardin
qu'il
objet de créer une sorte de petit
paradis replié sur lui même et en
hauteur
souvent on franchit des murs pour voir
agenda à celle inverse il faut être en
hauteur pour profiter du décor on
découvre la vallée de du lot est
absolument sublime
donc ce sont déjà organique
effectivement des jardins lumières ou le
minéral finalement ne vous permets que
de vous promener le minéral est dans la
logique l'eau minérale n'est pas
décoratifs
il n'y a pas de statut et remarquez ça
la statue c'est le végétal
c'est vraiment un jardin une conception
vraiment original et en tant que
jardinier est là baraton est-ce que
c'est difficile d'être jardinier d'un
jardin comme celui ci je crois que tous
les jardins sont difficiles à entretenir
ce qui est difficile dans un jardin
c'est de conserver l'âme du lieu
apprendre à tailler une paupière car il
s'agit de toutes pièces c'est pas plus
difficile finalement que de faire votre
métier à saveur de mener une discussion
simplement il y a un bon groupe et on
saute de respecter votre interlocuteur
est de faire en sorte que la
conversation correspondent à vos
attentes
eh bien le jardinier a pour mission
depuis en sorte que quand on franchit
les grilles de versailles le de
chenonceaux ou de marqueyssac on sera
transporté dans un autre univers que
l'on simple une des lieux et qu'on
puisse fait rêver je dis souvent qu'à un
beau jardin c'est un lieu de l'on quitte
à regret marqueyssac est un beau jardin
venez découvrir marqueyssac un soir on
était à la tombée de la nuit
c'est un lieu merveilleux toutes les
villes avoisinantes ont les lumières qui
apparaissent vous êtes là entre les
rangées de bruit c'est quelque chose de
merveilleux parce que marc les ags a une
âme et les nains de jardin vous leur
consacrer un court chapitre dans votre
livre
est-ce qu'il faut les détester les
jeunes managers nors le nahd jardin est
ma passion et mon regret j'aurais aimé
que l'on installe à versailles dans la
perspective royal 1 un géant
j'aurais adoré l'idée que ceux d'un se
voit même depuis
de versailles mais jeunes mâles je ne
m'appelle pas jeff koons jeff koons en
avait eu l'idée
tout le monde aurait crié au génie donc
moi on m'a refusé mon installation de
nadja la sq entre nous je comprends
aisément mais j'aime bien les nains de
jardin parce que je trouve ça drôle
encore et les jardins sont envahies de
nappes jardin en allemagne dans tous les
pays de l'est
incroyable cette passion en france il y
en a quelques-uns mais mais fort peu
mais j'avais des a d'ailleurs dénoncé à
l'époque sur les ondes d'une grande
station ce front de libération des nains
de jardin qui prenait les jardins dans
les jardins pour les libérer dans les
bois j'avais qualifié ces individus de
criminels car le notre jardin ne vient
pas des forêts mais des profondeurs de
la terre
il faut apprendre à mieux aimer jamin de
la dette le nahd jardin et vous
comprendrez tout grand mystère pas
content
à propos du nain de jardin il n'y a pas
de nêne aux jambes je me pose quelques
questions
c'est juste il ya un jardin dont vous
parlez dans ce livre que vous n'avez
jamais visité pourtant il est très
célèbre c'est central park
alors comment expliquer oui nous fait
que n'être jamais la centrale pas est-ce
parce que c'est un jardin artificielle
n'ont que ça vous déplaît parce que je
creuse était allé aux états unis je n'ai
pas eu le temps de visiter tout ce que
j'aurais aimé visiter centrale pas
besoin d'en parler parce que je ne le
connais pas je n'y ai pas mis les pieds
mais je l' ai tellement vu avec du style
justin hamad
quand il court dans kramer contre kramer
c'est là au japon qu'il faut croire dans
un sens et pas dans un autre
au risque de passer pour un petit peu un
quelqu'un qui n'est pas trader dans le
coup il ya également le film de chagall
et sharon stone
un justicier dans la ville où il commet
quelques massacres ou dans ceux dans ce
temps ce jardin de ce genre je le
connais pas je connais bien son histoire
le connaît pour l'avoir vu mille fois
dans des films à la télévision
donc je voulais en parler ce jardin date
d'une époque où les états unis ont été
capables et bien de se mettre du végétal
dans la ville et quand on regarde
central park quand vous allez sur google
et vous regardez la ville deux nuls en
vue d'en haut
vous faites ce rectangle par
on est coupé je trouve ça extraordinaire
que dans le pays le plus capitaliste du
monde
on était capable de préserver ce carré
devient dieu et est à paris paris a eu
la réputation d'avoir été très tôt dès
le 19ème siècle grâce à haussmann une
ville verte mallet à la fois de parcs de
jardin de square également est ce que
est ce que paris vous vous agrée en tant
que ville verte en tant que ville jardin
oui beaucoup plus qu'il n'est pas réparé
ce sont 500 jardins c'est considérable
qui sont pratiquement partout où il ya
de très grands jardins le luxembourg les
tuileries le pack monceaux de genre la
merveilleuse et on le doit effectivement
à un homme un empereur le napoléon iii
d'apollon 3 voulait que le peuple puisse
profiter des espaces place à
l'exposition à ce que soit ce que l'on
sait trop peu que les plus grands
jardins
je pense par exemple aux batignolles ce
sont des jardins pour été construits
dans des lieux terrible des lieux où
autrefois on se tue et ont massacré où
il y avait des dépotoirs et il a utilisé
des lieux terrible pour en faire des
espaces de plaisir donc les jardins de
paris oui son merveilleux
oui on travaille ce que je lis est là
paris est une ville où il ya pas mal
d'espacés quand on compare avec bien là
on a trop tendance en allemagne a compté
là toute la région autour de berlin
comme faisant partie de la ville par les
500 jardins des très grands des travaux
des tout petits avec des arts au
merveilleux je pense au marronnier
d'anne frank luck lui dans le score de
même nom et qui rappelle le partir de 7
cette jeune fille je pense à roda que
vous arrivez dans ce lieu d'être
accueillis pour le penseur en personne
et quand même de quoi être élu je pense
au luxembourg où il y a catherine de
médicis
on revient à l'italie qui a voulu ce
jardin oui paris une table de jardin est
vraiment exemplaire
jean françois colosimo est-ce qu'il est
toujours avec nous oui je suis là j'ai
fait des choix ciblés au jardin jean
françois on va d'abord je crois qu'il
faut fait ici
vraiment la barre at on pour vous faire
partager sa son immense passion avec
beaucoup de science aussi à le jardin
c'est l'humanisation de l'histoire du
cosmos c'est comme le colloque
commencent à se séparer de nature il
crée un enclos écrit un lieu clos dans
lequel il a reconstitué une nature selon
son goût son rêve son inspiration son
ordre donc c'est un phénomène
anthropologique fondamental se met très
juste un petit bémol à votre
conversation à tous les deux avec votre
permission
la bible ne parle pas de porc elle parle
d'un fruit défendu
c'est l'échographie occidentales qui ont
fait une porn est d'ailleurs la bible
parle de fruits défendus permet à qui
veut au fond d'imaginer le fruit qu'il
aimerait voir mais on a même dans cette
représentation c'est une olive ce qui
rejoindrait d'ailleurs la cerise à
d'alain baraton n'est ce pas dans lhassa
dans certaines fresques médiévales très
nourris pour et peep
peut-être parce qu'il ya un noyau et
vous avec la pomme a pris le dessus en
raison de cette idée de la pomme d'adam
c'est que le morceau de la pomme qu'à
manger adam lui rester en travers de la
gorge
depuis c'est ça le péché d'origine et
c'est pour ça qu'on coquette un peu
depuis
c'est un peu ça l'idée doit c'était
juste une petite précision de la bible
des habits et la bible de prix visite à
la pomme
elle parle de fruits défendus et c'est
tout pas dès maintenant je trouve que
l'on a beaucoup de chance d'avoir cette
très haute tradition qui remonte karman
qui fait le trait d'union dans
l'histoire de france qui nous mène à la
marathon qui qui donc je vois le
successeur de l'eau note cette
continuité dans l'histoire qui s'inscrit
en plus dans le paysage un paysage
humanisé c'est ça la france il faut dire
merci aussi certainement à toute une
génération de paysan d'agriculteur qui
nous offre rares paysages si divers mais
qui toujours qui a toujours un peu la
marque humaine quelque chose non pas de
fabriquer mais de façonner je sais pas
si vous êtes d'accord alain baraton mais
on est un pays extraordinaire de ce
point de vue là où on voit le travail
humain de buman isation de la nature un
mois elle a le talent de son nom marrant
jean françois colosimo a parfaitement
résumé ce qu'elle a l'âge
note pour la pomme est le fruit défendu
merci d'avoir corrigé c'est enthousiaste
parce que moi j'ai le bâtiment aux
tableaux anciens mais il est vrai que ce
que vous avez dit c'est que le jardin en
fait reflète l'état d'esprit d'un pays
vous avez bien justement presser cette
soupe raisonnement c'est ainsi que l'on
trouve du jardin chinois ou japonais
le jardin anglais on pourrait même
résumé ce faux propos par mon troll on a
tous au jardin je te dirai qui tu es car
le jardin reflète pas seulement la
personnalité d'une personne mais
également d'un pays
le livre s'intitule dictionnaire
amoureux illustré desjardins il est
finie alain baraton il est paru chez
plon et gründ merci tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]